apparently new mutants is sticking to
its release date anywho
they have unveiled an opening scene i
guess what the big thing is that they
said they would unveil here
surprise so we're gonna watch this
opening scene immediately followed by
the comic con
teaser trailer let's just see what's
going on with this movie
there's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
this is mirage
is all things good that's my guess
compassion love
trust the other is all things
evil fear shame
and self-destruction
[Music]
[Music]
wow never mind
still though
[Music]
i have to go back stay here
[Music]
oh wow
that's stuck
is it the bear that's going after yeah
probably
[Music]
[Applause]
hospital yeah
how would you i've killed someone
if you weren't here you've been present
or worse
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's play
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it only took like three years later and
a whole bunch of trailers to get to the
powerhouse like this looks like the
coolest thing in the world
yeah it looks pretty intense that looks
awesome
that looks so awesome so it looks like
the one who's gonna have the biggest
emotional journey is gonna be mirage
especially from the fact that you're
starting with their opening scene
she's even at this experimental facility
she's still being terrorized by the
i don't know what the hell what's that
bear i don't know the name of that bear
but
her and her family are terrorized by
that bear demon bear
the hero of it will be anya taylor joy's
me like she'll be the lead hero but the
big
heart and maybe the whole emotional
journey will be with the character
mirage right
i thought this was awesome this is the
best of new mutants has ever looked i
would just go
i would say that just off of its like
minute and a half comic con teaser
trailer as far as the opening scene goes
it's still not enough to really make you
go like oh this will be a good movie
i've seen plenty of movies in my time
where the opening scene is awesome and
then like fantastic beasts and the
crimes are going to wall had a pretty
cool opening scene and then the rest of
the movie was
and i'm not saying it's going to be that
case i have faith that this movie will
be
cool i have faith that i will enjoy this
movie a lot but the opening say i
thought the visuals were great
the mood and the tone was cool now it's
just more about like
pacing because there were times where i
couldn't tell if they the chaos
not actually you know what the chaotic
editing i thought was that was
to service the emotional turmoil and the
intensity of the situation she was in
at the time and really capturing it from
her perspective like i like when her dad
gets taken away and thrown back at her
you're just staying focused on her the
whole time and come to find out that oh
you're
in the mutant facility the whole time
yeah and i mean in terms of a pg-13
horror twinged movie two i thought that
was really effective pretty big impact
yeah
yeah especially again it's an old school
idea but yeah you just
close up on her as you have the sound of
the carnage going off screen and you can
just feel all the terror and anguish you
would ever need without actually having
to see it and plus that builds you up
for once it could look like we actually
get the hero shot at the end
um and it it seems interesting to me
because yeah
putting you in the shoes of danny at the
start of the movie and with
at least all the press releases being
like oh she's gonna be kind of the
villainous character
i wonder if maybe that's making way for
some kind of arc by the end where she
won't
leave this movie a villain or something
like that but either way i mean i like
the idea
of taking danny being the villain or
mirage
mirage but i mean they've said that like
some of these things that they're
experiencing
might be or their speculation that their
hallucinations she's bringing on to them
so maybe there would be like a
villainous aspect but without the
like malevolence from her or something
like that or she's learning about these
powers because what makes me curious is
the other stuff like the
you know crooked man looking guy and
yeah the freddy krueger things like
poking through the walls
i mean i'm thinking that what's
happening is that those creatures
uh are from that demonic realm limbo so
that's where we're gonna get all these
other kinds of like
crazy it seems like these guys are gonna
be pitched as
truly psychologically tormented
characters whatever
powers they have they'll probably
conjure up a lot of trouble
for each other in the beginning but
eventually by the end they'll learn
to really wield or work with their
powers
it's like mirage seems like the kind of
character who's so
tormented that she's kind of got this
repressed personality on
eventually she's gonna find that inner
hero within her i'm not more curious
about all the other characters that
we're looking at
cannonball wolf spain sunspot all those
guys because
right now all my focus is is really
going towards magic and mirage
you know yeah it seems like this the
movie wants the trailers and the
marketing even the opening scene is
having you think more about them than
anyone else
yeah and it made me really curious about
what the werewolfing effects are gonna
be like because most of maisie williams
in this
look is just her and there's one shot
where she's kind of rolling out of the
transformation onto the ground which is
one of those things that i feel like is
maybe gonna be a little awkward for this
movie because it's a pg-13
they're gonna have to do a whole bunch
of cheating like she's not really nude
yeah i i hope that that element cause
like a lot of the effects they showcase
here look really cool and ominous and i
hope that the werewolf
uh look pulls off well basically because
there's so many
other elements to this and i feel like
that's one that kind of needs to be on
point more so than like a demon hench or
something like that yeah
what i'm hoping for this movie does is
that they really just
hound home the horror and the craziness
of that that way when you get the rise
of the heroes in the end you get a
cathartic experience of like
yes you know hopefully hopefully
we'll see we'll see and i feel like the
pg-13 like if he really carries
that tone and uses the fact that you can
swap out the blood for superhero stuff
you could wind up with a pretty chilling
pretty like adrenaline-pumping horror
superhero flick so
here's hoping end of august we'll be
there all right guys what did you think
of this opening scene
what did you think of this comic-con
trailer leave your thoughts down below
are you excited for this i mean i feel
covering so much new mutants lately
all right do you believe the movie
existed
so you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video
up we'll see what else p catches our
interest coming outside of comic con
last but not least let's do a p
daniel gallagher our friend who comes
and goes in the message
threads but has stayed pledged for the
longest of times
my favorite kind of picture i'm just
kidding no interest
the beautiful thing about daniel is that
with his
job uh working as a pharmacist i imagine
that he's probably landed himself in
some kind of new mutant situation
perhaps maybe not a mutant but some kind
of
experiment gone wrong i think daniel the
reason why we haven't been hearing from
him is because he's been combining all
kinds of medication
illegally behind everyone's back to try
to garner himself some superpowers but
now he looks like some weird deformed
scottish guy
who has the ability to go into like a
blob like
power and then seep his way through
cracks and walls
that would actually be pretty he's found
a lot of ladies who love that kind of
fetish
that's that's a good way to do that it's
good to keep it consensual
gallagher you find those fetishists i
mean scottish are a lot more lenient
than we are here in the states
most places
[Music]
what's up with you scott scott well he's
a freak like a mutant
oh hey that's the message of x-men
messages they're all freaks
you